listen guys my name is Ryan right Lisa
you go next Tyrone Magnus is here isn't
this exciting and we also have a white
girl here isn't that also exciting don't
worry guys she's a talented white girl
she's a blond hair blue eyes yeah is
this it's the best that you can get on
this plane the black school love the
blonde blue eyes you know that means
black so unified association is great
great great great listen we're gonna get
to this video eventually five supposedly
cursed YouTube videos from top five
unknowns alright let's see um let's see
if reactions are in here cuz we're the
cancer of youtube thanks for defending
this jinx don't you call our friends
over at watch this they produce good
quality content about an array of topics
there are things in nature scientific
content so these what about check them
out and both subscribe to them
while these videos actually cast maybe I
guess we'll only know after we watch
them
number 5 w PK e PK w the version I could
find if this video was uploaded onto
YouTube
in October of 2014 however the video
keeps disappearing
so the original upload date is unknown
when the video was originally uploaded a
rumor started to spread of the people
started to complain on a strange side
effect after viewing the video it's
believed that the video doesn't appear
for everyone and it's sometimes
extremely hard to find the video simply
shows a blurred image of what looks like
a person's face the face is distorting
and some eerie tones can be heard
playing in the background there have
been rumors to where the video came from
some have ranged from a government
experiment gone wrong to a person's
final moments on camera the vineyard
center courts fear and paranoia and also
one strange technological side effect
some claim that after watching the video
once they're no longer able to find it
and this is when the curves picked over
their computer images of the distorted
face will randomly pop up and it's also
reported that the day in which you are
going to die will also pop up next
theory was tested out by a youtuber
called I Triple E while after watching
the video that claimed it took over
their computer and they caught the cars
on tape here is at the cursed video
I don't work I'm not no [ __ ]
like books on washing my pillow
the Ferrari race wet coats
ah midnight curse uploaded in March of
2013 a youtuber by the name of shrouded
hand at this creepy clip sent into them
it simply shows a kleenex commercial the
commercial alone is quite bizarre and
has some creepy singing playing along
with it however what the cameraman
caught was far more scary on the
original video people in the comments
claimed that once a clock struck
midnight the video changed into utter
creepiness the cameraman decided to put
this to the test and actually caught
something on tape he placed the video at
11:59 and it seems to play fine but once
it turns to midnight he plays it again
at this time the video plays is normal
light takes a frightening time the
singing becomes distorted and so does
the visuals the video then looks as if
it's bugging out and a YouTube player
then fades
it's believed that this happens every
night at midnight but only ever exactly
on midnight
[Music]
I'm not looking Wow
this is a great reaction silicide mouse
dot avi what only this in a previous
list but as it was said to be cursed we
just had to include it again this video
has been circulated on the internet for
a while but the one that was uploaded
onto YouTube dates back to 2012 however
the original animation is believed to
date back to the 1930s it's said to be a
lost episode of a film collection of old
Disney animations from the 1930s which
were re-released on DVD
however this animation was seen as too
bland and boring and was never released
but is believe I got leaked onto the
Internet the animation simply shows
Mickey Mouse strolling in front of
buildings and this continues on a
constant loop the creepy aspect of the
animation is the music it isn't your
typical cheerful Disney music it's an
eerie downtempo piano tune the audio
then transforms into a strange
disturbing white noise type of sound
after this a woman has heard screaming
it's rumored that the screams of real
recordings of a woman being raped by the
end the visuals become quite distorted
and it fades to a picture of Mickey's
face and a Russian text that translates
to the sights of hell brings its viewer
back in it said that after viewing the
video the witness may feel fear
depression paranoia and also suicidal
thoughts there was also a rumor that
after watching the video somebody had
shot themselves with a handgun just off
the saying these words real suffering is
not known enjoy the video
oh my god is so creepy
Oh number two okay ritual curse uploaded
in 2015 there isn't much information
surrounding this video but it's believed
to be cursed it's said that the only way
to fill the curse
I'll get the full effect of the video is
to perform an opera jewel you're meant
to turn off all the lights and wear
headphones there are images like stars
and then certain pictures pop up this
includes a picture of something in a
road so audio is a strange mixture of
sounds which sounds quite like something
you'd hear in a sci-fi movie it's
believed to be a method of subliminal
messaging and hypnotism it's also
allegedly puts the viewer in a
trance-like State one strange effect of
the curse that has been reported is
numbness it's been said that the video
leaves that viewers body numb up until
they die the lights have to be off guys
oh yeah and you have to wear headphones
number one the arena moody god bless
well this video has been circulating on
the internet since 2008 and it's been
reloaded to YouTube many times the video
shows him out with a blank look on his
face covered with a red tin as the video
goes on his facial expressions change
and there's become quite sinister let's
begin to stop rolling around inside his
head along with this creepy deep
laughter can be heard along with the
sound of bells it's believed that the
video is cursed and whoever can make it
throughout the entire video are lucky
there is a story behind the video that
claims back when it was first uploaded
in 2008 it caused more than 100 plus
people to try and gouge their eyes out
it's alleged that this is what caused it
to be removed and causes the upload as
account to be suspended
other effects of the video include fear
but the main aspect of the curse is
believed to be the urge to gouge your
own eyes out
would I do it guys did I do it someone
gave me the fork
[Music]
don't think so
thank you so much enjoyed the video then
it so give it a big thumbs oh don't
forget subscribe to keep updated with
our videos goodbye feel like I was
sexually assaulted Wow oh okay
you see I I'm not even gonna feel creepy
Ryan I'm sorry Tyrone Magnus I'm sorry
Lisa mihalick I'm not religious I'm not
but I did grow up Catholic in the
subconscious of my brain when I hear
cursed and like demonic and whatever
kind of [ __ ] my mind instantly believes
that that is probably a real thing right
there I've never wonder those beep I'm
so gullible like all this [ __ ] I
immediately just believe whatever top
five unknowns is saying I'm like I don't
ever go that's fake oh my god
so the Mickey Mouse one really freaked
me out that was [ __ ] creepy
I mean they all freaked me out the
Mickey Mouse one was so like the
original Mickey Mouse I know and then
they sounds like a woman getting raped
something like that in the Russian text
and they say someone killed themselves
over that yeah Wow I think we should do
reactions to these cursed YouTube videos
yeah me too Allenby come on guys no Lisa
oh yeah I'm the Asian one you're the
white one you're the black one we make
the perfect reaction trio I could barely
get through just the clips I was hiding
my eyes with this pillow
I was hiding your eyes I was making sure
he was okay I mean how are you making
sure time Rome is okay what were you
doing I wasn't looking there's a little
box here of this of the video playing
how do we know were you like comforting
him with your
oh my god are you doing a good job get
me in trouble and why girls stop coming
on the channel the first video doesn't
seem that creepy to me the one with the
blurry face oh come on no it looks like
a Picasso painting as they started with
that one
so you weren't knowing what you were
gonna expect after that so that was
creepy
yeah oh I know but the creepy part of
that was when they predict when you're
gonna die
ya know which is gonna be for me 2050 -
OH
hmm well I am I am yeah it's primarily
drugs I wake up in the morning snort
some adderall then when I get a crash I
do some cocaine for the rest of my guys
II don't wanna start off the morning
doing cocaine and afterwards you know
like after walking around heroin in my
ass I finally just inject some of that
[ __ ] mmm you know smoke some we didn't
like to chill out a little bit maybe
down some alcohol with some vicodin I'll
be the one that finds the cursed Kleenex
commercial you know why that shit's
cursed right you know why that Kleenex
is cursed
why come on come on you know why it's
cursed what these people sometimes use
Kleenex is full what's origami oh no not
that okay the word we're looking for is
semen Oh ejaculation into the tissue
clean up clean up
Kleenex Lennox clean the thing that you
often use if you don't have a sock
around that was very educational
it was very informative in my personal
life well what we wanted that to do with
the video
bird's-eye view and because they were
saying no that's why it's cursed it's
because it was Satan's semen oh you seem
it of the devil my skin through the
videos to see what to discussing and it
came on the image of the okay
appeared the image of the the world no
that was that was disturbing I didn't
miss it but that was way too clear for
me I want to do that same exact video
but put like like a naked rabbi in there
and said you know okay it's like a naked
rabbi no no Tyron should be in there no
just swinging his dick over his shoulder
because he has big black [ __ ] ELISA look
at him as I tell you this please don't
look at me this near anyone Bobby will
you stop there you go keep your eyes on
him the last one the marina more to Garg
less gorg that was close that guy sick I
don't know who that guy is messed up too
but people want to gouge their eyes out
I don't know what can really just
because his sanity said and it was like
making my eyes tingle yeah mess with me
too
oh really yeah and then it's like the
focus on his eyes but I was creeped out
well you're in denial
really feeling I would never want to do
that I don't I heard his story once
about this guy who took no girl who took
shrooms thought hair was growing out of
her eyeball so she shaved her eyeball by
the way restrooms like five years now
the one drug I haven't done if you guys
can find me some shrooms I will gladly
pay you you you know look it isn't
I'll pay interest you know you pay a
hundred for it I'll give you under
twenty we could do shrooms here you
gotta do with people that you feel safe
with and you trust you really aren't the
first person who taught me to do you
think that would like make you go oh
maybe I should dial it back I'm used to
it
oh stop skipping through the video dude
okay okay that's some creepy [ __ ] cursed
YouTube videos if you guys want to see
Tyrone magnets do the reaction blow up
his channel with requests just blow them
up with requests that he's now way more
subs than I do so just just let him know
and he'll do answer your watch all the
cursed YouTube videos for you and Lisa
will guest star on Tyrone's channel for
that come on
yeah you guys would have a great time
they say fear can excite the genitals
that's why horror movies are a great
date every Saw movie I had sex
afterwards
every song torture porn is the girl's
favorite okay if you want to know woman
comment I'll tell you what it's all
about
say what it's all about knowing a woman
Lisa can back me okay
so I'm Lisa mihalick she'll be a lot of
people cringing during this this is
cringe-worthy and I don't blame you
well if you guys want something unique
you can subscribe today to the real
rejects label yourself or reject after
that subscribe a Tyrone's channel become
a magnesite that's right where he can
reach 1 million subscribers that's his
thing that's his catchphrase now you do
it let's do it all together
alright one two three woo Lisa mihalick
has an Instagram where there are photos
of her half naked everywhere
hey guys guys some followers are only in
your imagination this guy's some
followers well you can look at her
photos and imagine what she looks like
if you pervert sir you can't well you
guys are perverts oh you [ __ ] lunch
drivers are perverts I thought I was a
pervert you're the real perverts hmm all
you subscribers shouldn't Asti
[ __ ] out there let's give a
shout out to one us subscribers
Matt Rodriguez okay Ryan please please
please please let me do some reaction
video with you I'm down for movie
trailers any reaction with you
I always watch your channel and I like
to start my channel one day and
hopefully have you on there and be part
of it I'm in the Chino area off the 60
freeway everyone Matt Rodriguez is off
the chino area up to 60 freeway it
wouldn't mind driving and shoot some
reactions with you you are god and
hilarious please get back to me
Matt Rodriguez this is my way of getting
back to you first I will see what you
look like if you're worthy enough to be
on camera okay I'm not gonna lie you
give like a serial killer vibe like no
joke even with a cute little lightsaber
I'd still like that's [ __ ] like kylo
Ren's brother separated at birth and
this photo with you with Willy Wonka I
feel like you're about to stick your
penis in Willy Wonka I'm just saying man
I don't know if I can have you on the
channel when I'm worried you'll just
want to stick your penis in me the whole
time
cuz I'm afraid you might do it without
my permission and then I'm afraid I
might be into it which would just made
me even more afraid because I might like
it and something's wrong with me so
you're making me question my sexuality
Matt and uh we'll talk about this okay
I'm sorry guys Tyrell would you like to
say anything in that
[Music]
[Laughter]